enfin montrent un honneur bref un temps
éternel mérité ce te fais
on dire merci
merci aux poètes pour une mélodie si
belle qu'elle nous semble déjà familière
pourtant cet enregistrement est inédit
85 ans et plus de 1000 chansons le
talent du fou chantant semble éternelle
ce sont deux les amis une facilité
d'écriture déconcertante que le poète
lui seul c'est le déchiffrer c'est en la
mineur mais non c'est pas ça qu'il faut
repart en continu jusqu'à la fin de ses
on revient à ben bella mais je me trouve
pas mal j'ai une certaine admiration
pour moi ne propose pas trop grande
quand même ce serait ridicule mais je me
vois tel que je suis c'est pour ça que
je me vois avec mes défauts mais mes
défauts bandar monachon incurable des
défauts que même la nouvelle génération
semble ne pas discerner
le mener la première j'aime bien chaque
année parce que j'ai j'entends beaucoup
c'est ses chansons s'impose ouais moi
aussi un peu des fois j des belles
choses alors maman dis chapeau est un
prénom
dans la boue
un hymne au printemps des poètes écrit
en 48 heures seulement
pour cet hommage que charles trenet
offre à ceux qui nous font rêver
la beauté
oui
non